malfunctions
0 points 11 o'clock there were two breaks of the
side and the other
on the other side did not hit the old ones and
so gradually valera
although the ding-dong just had a terrible
terrible blow at the grandmother how many
young consciousness
I how would you become a handle then the
clouds are you understood what I am  quickly and
simply lateral
amirov we approached the comfort and the handle, I could not
let go and suddenly 1 channel to your fingers is
strong you Senka it can be a rocket and
bits of it I think that the cassette
because the goal was one bolt was
one explosion of soap but it seemed to me so
on  the night the echo was coming to me it seemed to the post in
that direction and there was such a rumble like whether
it was a rocket flying or whether it was a plane of the
summer gods, it was important for letting me see and the
firemen had already arrived on the roof, but they
quickly localized it all
quickly there, sort of like a man, well
, somewhere  failed, they pulled him out, but he is
alive and well, everything is fine, he
has stood since the beginning of the war for three months,
they didn’t take him out, they thought he would return again
pity today at 6
am people know my body is stranded by rockets
and who destroyed everything is broken we take out for the
time being trade you are
so sorry very much of course so much work
so much effort well someone 2 made
me laugh